good afternoon welcome to everyone uh my
name is Victoria ston Cadena I am the
associate director here at rhym as part
of our mission as a center we are tasked
with supporting research efforts across
the university that center around issues
of race indigeny and transnational
migration in that effort R rhm supports
research and Conference attendance for
both undergraduate and graduate students
throughout the year we are delighted to
welcome you all for this three minute
research showcase as we hear from Yale
graduate students who conducted research
with our support this past summer each
student is asked to synthesize their
research in under three minutes using
just one slide while challenging um it
is always exciting to hear the
highlights of important research being
done across the campus which includes
researchers tonight from this afternoon
from over 11 different departments as
you can see in the program here after
each student presents we will have time
for one to two questions and then we'll
invite the next speaker we invite you to
join us afterwards for some light
refreshments and conversation I would
like to take a moment to give a special
thanks to Ryan win for who is a
Woodridge fellow with us with rhm this
year for all his work and preparation of
this event likewise I'd like to thank
the rest of the rhm team for their
support as well and keeping this timely
I will now turn this over to
Harry thank
you good afternoon everyone um thank you
Ryan and ren for organizing and for
giving me the opportunity to offer you a
little glimpse of what I've been working
on this summer um on the slide you see
an engraving by Abraham boss of actors
performing at the hotel de Buona in
Paris is most prominent permanent stage
in the
1630s notice how the actor's bodies are
opened up to the audience the way the
performers are arranged shows
consideration for stylized physicality
in the stage picture notice too the
costumes the different styles the
captain with the huge rough the lovers
and their lavish
outfits materials that likely had
Origins Way Beyond France Testament to
France's growing Colonial Empire finally
notice the unembellished in small stage
all this relates to a tradition of
traveling companies when costumes and
props were easier to move and sets and
where physicality and visuality were
important when voices didn't carry
significantly this image depicts not
just characters but real people the
actors you see here were some of the
most celebrated French actors of their
time and many of them performed not only
in Paris but also across the country and
as far as Belgium and the Netherlands
for example Shir and his wife Isabelle M
Messier that the troop of the prince of
orange some 10 years earlier um before
this image was drawn bringing their
performances to the court in the ha and
to other cities across the low
countries the performance cultures of
the Netherlands and France were closely
connected in the archives I found
significant similarities in language and
content of court orders that gave actors
permission to perform as well as in the
size of the playing spaces furthermore
these were actors working in Paris as
well as across France in the low
countries bringing with them style and
technique thus by studying French
sources I was able to discover more
about what performance in the ha might
have looked like and thus what the
performance of ponai Sid could have been
like when it was performed there in
1638 while chiefly presented as a play
about impossible love the Sid is a
political adaptation of a medieval
Spanish Legend a response to the
centralization of power in France by
Rish and Louis the 13th the war with
Spain and France's expanding Colonial
project my dissertation explores how
four of the most popular Productions of
the first decade of Amsterdam City
Theater
transformed as they transferred from
across Europe and what implications that
has on an understanding of Dutch
Imperial narratives and identity
formation at the time this semester I am
considering the purpose and consequences
of the s's circulation how would
audiences in the Haag and subsequently
Amsterdam relate to this story of a
Spanish national hero at a time when
both France and the Netherlands were at
war with Spain how could the different
local contexts have informed reception
and finally how might the character
reflect a supernational Christian
European self-fashioning in opposition
to the Islamic Empires to the East and
the South if you have any thoughts or
questions I would love to hear from you
thank
[Applause]
you thank you hi everybody hi all
right so um I study ancient religious
texts especially the Hebrew Bible within
the religious studies Department
and what uh about that I'm most
interested is contemporary interpretive
approaches that communities develop
towards um meaning and practice so even
more fascinating about that is the power
dynamics that come into play in the
interpretation process noting the fact
that uh the predominant interpretive
approaches and Frameworks for a long
time have all been white um eurocentric
so some of the key questions for me
beyond what the B what is the Bible is
how do we read it and that's um what
other non worting approaches are there
so taking a postcolonial approach my
research explores indigenous knowledge
systems namely African oral culture
literature history um including Proverbs
riddle riddles sorry uh story forms
novels cultural songs myths mythologies
um
EXC um you know to explore new
Frameworks that there might be to
capture African realities um while also
contributing to the ongoing discussion
on the centering whiteness and
multi-racial liing biblical
interpretation in biblical studies so
with support from ritm I had to Ghana a
West African country with a rich
cultural heritage and an important
history of colon colonization
colonialism Independence and religion
and my research took me to various
Institutions and sites to observe and to
talk to key Scholars or already doing
similar work so to name a few some of
the pictures you see here I went to the
University of Ghana I went to The Bible
Society of Ghana a chassi university a
Kofi Chrystal Institute of theology ad
Mission Methodist University Trinity
Theological Seminary and aside from
spending hours talking to several
Scholars and graduate students um at
these institutions I audited classes
visited you know libraries spent some
time at various
archives um and outside of the
University world I went to the um quing
uh Museum in the middle picture to
explore Ghana's West Ghana and West
Africa's history you know I also went to
the slavery U the cape Coast um slave
Castle uh to explore Africa's history
with slavery and col colonization
Independence and especially aspects of
those that intersect with my interest in
indigeny and you know newer forms
postcolonial interpretive approaches um
two key moments for me among these were
classes that I audited on translation
and
inculturation and uh my visit to uh the
missions archives at AI chrysa Institute
of theology I think that they opened up
for me A Whole New World of
interpretation that is rooted in uh
European Le translation while also
exposing me to the potential of language
and language Theory translation theory
for the success of my entire project
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay hi everyone uh my name is saana I'm
a PhD student in sociology uh and today
I'll will be sharing with you all my
project uh titled post deportation
repeat migration uh intend to
reimatec American immigrants and I
presented uh my working paper uh with
the supportive Rhythm this past summer
so despite their limited access to
healthc care and exclusion from
mainstream institutions Latinos in the
US display lower mortality and morbidity
rates than their native and white
counterparts and this Health Advantage
is often described as the so-called
Hispanic Health Paradox and it's
believed to be a result of the selection
of immigrants who migrate to and from
the US for instance research finds that
healthier people are more likely to
migrate and those who are unhealthy are
more likely to return home to seek
medical treatment family support or to
die however changes an immigration
policy and enforcement has shaped
selection and to return migration as
immigrants can either voluntarily or
involuntarily return home through
deportation but despite the record
number of deportations in the past two
decades the health status of immigrants
who return to the US after being
deported remains largely unknown and
this is critical to understand because
even though there are significant legal
repercussions for attempting to return
to the US after deportation
um uh research continues to that
deportees who are deported will uh be
more than likely to return to the us
sometime in the future so my study takes
a step towards capturing the
complexities of immigrant Health by
examining the health status of recently
deported Central American immigrants who
intend to return to the US relative to
their peers who will stay in their
country of origin and I drawn data from
the survey of migration in the southern
border of Mexico also known as am Su
which is a cross-sectional survey that
is highly representative of the
Salvadoran uran and water and adults who
are detained and deported back to
Central America between 2012 and 2020
and overall I find that depor who intend
to return to the US are more likely to
say that they have poor health relative
to their healthier peers who plan on
staying in Central America and I also
find that deportees uh who report
negative experiences during their
apprehension and detention are more
likely to have poor health so these
findings suggest that the health
selection that Health selection is a
complex process that cannot offer a
simple explanation for the health
outcome of Latinos in particular this
could be a result of the Hispanic Health
Paradox being uh developed at a
different historical moment and it also
may fall short in explaining the health
outcomes of contemporary immigrants in
an era of mass
deportation and as punitive immigration
policies continue to change and
deportations continue to rise it's
important to explicitly examine the
population movement and selection of
what I call Post deportation repeat
migrants to further understand how they
navigate life after their deportation
thank
[Applause]
you hi everyone I am Dianna and I'm a
second year in the history PhD
program um Gonzalo Gonzalez the subject
of the right-hand article over there was
a workingclass Mexican revolutionary and
Baker who migrated to New York City
during the 1920s shortly after being
laid off from his Bakery job in 1929 he
became an active member of the Communist
party's Latina chapter in New York in
the summer of 1930 he was assassinated
by the nypg at a March that protested
the death of a black comrade who had
also been killed by the
police around the time that gono was
assassinated he was one of over 4,000
Mexicans living in New York City
Mexicans represented less than 5% of the
city's Latina population a relatively
smaller percentage compared to that of
other ethnic groups from Latin America
and the
Caribbean however The Life and Legacy of
Gonzalez demonstrate that Mexicans held
visible and meaningful roles in a city's
labor and leftist movements of the
post-world war I era while Gonzalez was
one of the more remarkable organizers in
the city hundreds of other working-class
Mexican migrants were also active
members in LST labor and political
organizations Gonzalez's narrative
guides my current research on radical
Mexican political culture in post World
War I New York over the summer I became
interested in taking a more translocal
approach by identifying connections or
networks that may have been established
between leftist Latina or Mexican
chapters in New York City and me and the
Mexican Communist party or the mCP with
support from RM I spent some time in
Mexico City
visiting during my AR visits I sorted
through the periodicals of el machete
which was the mcp's official newspaper
between 1924 to
1938 I came across a handful of articles
that confirmed an ongoing dialogue
between Mexican leftist in New York and
Mexico in some instances Mexican Yorkers
invited leaders of the mCP to deliver
speeches and
conventions in other occasions Mexican
Communists in New York organized Mutual
Aid events uh aimed at fundraising F
machete as shown in the bottom left
perhaps the most exciting moment of
transnational leftist encounters that I
came across was when erand Lae director
of el machete attended a commemoration
event in 1936 honoring the sixth year
anniversary of Gonzalez's death
discussed on the right- hand article the
periodical that I came across generated
important questions for my research for
example to what extent that these
ongoing translocal encounters shape
radical leftist movement in New York
City and Mexico City what were the
Contours of this dialectical process I
look forward to addressing these
questions in my ongoing social history
research on Gonzalez and the lives of
workingclass Mexicans in post World War
I New York thank
[Applause]
you okay hi everyone I'm Sophia fourth
year in sociology and AFM um the title
of my project is how youth creates race
in the 21st century really it's an
attempt to look differently at the
increased vulnerability that young black
people and others of color face in the
wake of both 2020s racial violence and
the neglect of young people um in the
national response to co 19 this comes
especially as conflict arises between
racial and youth related public desire
so for example the premature return to
unsafe School conditions justified by
keeping afloat minority um and
Adolescent development but then
condemning the teaching of black history
with CLA claims of being unsuitable for
children in light of these tensions I
explore how black youth in particular
manage these ideological conflicts
between constructions of race and youth
um and the impact on that of that
relationship um on policy and sense of
self so this slide today represents two
of three parts to the project um the
first is archivally tracing what I see
as this relationship historically how do
ideas about race Infuse ideas about what
it means to be young so I trace the rise
of um race science and its view on
adolescent development how fears peer
pressure intersected with fears of
school integration things like that and
then um the second part is interviews
with young black people so I use my RTM
funding to compensate them so I don't
have pictures of them obviously um but I
wanted to talk about one shift that I
found between these kind of 20th century
management tactics that I found in the
archives and what I'm noticing now in my
interviewees um because the 21st century
Trayvon generation so to speak is a
Coming of Age process that's actually
characterized by the ubiquity of racial
violence online
online so young youth of color have
always held a voice in their communities
um and networked with each other over
racial issues through media um and how
they spoke about these racial issues was
tied to ideas about youth so this poem
on the right was written by a
15-year-old after World War II um and
racial campaigns around that she was
writing in the junior section of the
Chicago Defender black newspaper um this
picture in the middle was a panel of
black teens who was invited to speak um
on a TV show about uh youth delinquency
and its racial associations in 1965
right so around different racial riots
um but now during events of racial
violence the actual form of
communication or media is appearing to
have an increased impact on the approach
to Coming of Age um in comparison to the
event itself right so the social media
accounts that you make as an adolescent
right of passage um that cultivate your
friendships and so on so this quote at
the bottom comes from an interviewee who
was talking about a police brutality
incident that happened the same weekend
as his prom and how his Twitter feed was
like really in Slaughter because of the
different types of posts that were being
shared and he says it's like everyone's
on Twitter sharing pictures of prom and
I'm here on Twitter sharing pictures of
a dead person they're like but this is
our youth like okay but this is mine so
I'm really just interested in knowing
how we can pay better attention to
ideals about what constitutes youth how
might ideas of race be informing that in
ways we might not be noticing that could
be causing strife and overwhelm um
because I really think knowing more
about how these relationship
relationships are produced can kind of
give us another Le to dismantle them
from thank
[Applause]
you hi everyone I have notes but I don't
really like reading from notes so I'm
going to try to just do it from memory
um so uh latinx folks here in the United
States are the rapid most rapid growing
group to convert to Islam and I'm Focus
focusing on Mexico
specifically
um pretty much a lot of the major cities
in Mexico have mosques and melas which
are like small prayer rooms uh but what
I was fascinated by to hear was that in
chapas San Christal deas kasas chapas um
in a rural area there's an indigenous
group soil Mayans that were rapidly
converting to Islam and that really uh
captured my attention so um they're
roughly about 400 to 500 soil indigenous
people who converted to Islam in the
year
1995 so from 1995 to present there's
roughly about 400 to 500 Muslims um they
live in a majority Catholic area um many
of them were either Catholic or
Evangelical Christians before they
converted to Islam so my question was
like what led this specific Community to
convert to Islam um living in a rural
part of Mexico where Catholicism is like
the main mainstream religion What
attracted them to
Islam and um also the peculiar thing
about this group is like they converted
like across a span of like three
generations and within one family and so
that was interesting to me as well and
so when I visited Chiapas over the
summer I was able to conduct um roughly
about 30 oral interviews and I was able
to live alongside um a lot of the
community members there cuz there's five
different Muslim communities there and
so I was able to visit each one um and
so how did Islam come to Chiapas a
Spanish Muslim um by the name of nafia
came to Spain from Spain to Mexico in
1994 to chiapa specifically and he
wanted to convert um commandante Marcos
and the sabatista so he he's a
revolutionary himself so he's like I
want to combine like this Revolution and
Islam and Joint Forces well commandante
Marcos wasn't having it so then he went
to other saptist and he was successful
in converting them um and so actually
Muhammad Amin who was a saptist he was
the first to convert to Islam so that's
another question that I was asking like
connecting sapath ismo and that
revolutionary Spirit was there like a
connection to Islam there I
found that there was I mean I don't have
a lot of time to get into it but that's
one of the questions I want to like
further explore um the main reason
reason I gathered why people converted
to Islam was that they were really
attracted to the fact that it didn't see
so much as like a religion to them they
said they didn't feel like they had to
adhere to like rules and strictness it
was more of like a way of life and it
was
monotheistic um here in the photo that I
have on the screen this is a photo of
Four Women on Eid which is a Muslim
religious holiday and as you can see
they're dressed in their um traditional
soil clothing and while they're wearing
their hijabs SL rosos um I was really
interested in like the connection
between the hijab and if they found that
it was for forign or or what like how
did they feel living in Mexico and
observing the hijab and they said that
basically like their mothers and their
grandmothers were rosos some of them
were rosos when they were younger and so
wearing the hijab didn't seem something
like too far off or foreign to them and
it's kind of cool cuz I don't think in
this picture but um some of them wear
their traditional rosos still as their
hijabs and so um yeah and so another
when I interviewed a Muslim leader there
Name by the name of ibraim I asked him
if there was a connection to like
indigeneity and Islam and he said that
his grandfather actually converted to
Islam because he found a lot of
similarities with the religion of Islam
to his indigenous Roots just to give you
one example is the prostrations that
Muslims for performed during their five
daily prayers he said that his
grandfather was already um performing
some of those similar prostrations
during his prayers um following his
indigenous faith and so he it resonated
with his grandfather and that's how him
and his whole entire family converted to
Islam and what I found most interesting
during my research trip was to see how
sabatha revolutionaries were converting
to Islam but also how women found a lot
of um quoting like quote unquote
Liberation Freedom um and I mean I when
I heard them it's their words not mine
but when I heard them say that it was
interesting to me because they said the
outside world of Mexico sees them as a
press but they're like we actually feel
feel like we're not oppressed um at all
and
so um what I hope to do on my next trip
is Omar who's a for former sap Batista
he has a room full of old like newspaper
clippings and articles and they're all
like I mean they're like filled like up
to here and I didn't have enough time to
go through all of them but I'm curious
to just learn more about the saptist and
their conversions to Islam and also just
about this indigenous uh community that
like is continuing to Islam is growing
within such a small place like sanist
deasa
so hi everyone my name is uh Christian
um sixth year PhD in history
um so yeah I this summer I I spent um
some time doing uh Consulting some
archives specifically the standard food
company archives in New Orleans in lane
and um the wiing will our uh collections
in Princeton
um so yeah that's just the quote that
you uh I would translate in a few but I
wanted to um speak more broadly about
another event um in the summer of 1983
James Carney later known as Padre Lupe a
US Jesuit priest turn Guerilla left the
nican Border Village to Alano at
Honduras near the puka River with a 96
men Guerilla group called the Central
American revolutionary Workers Party
prtc led by former Dr Jose Maria Rees
Mata who was once a friend of chear a
few weeks later around mid-september B
Lupe most of his comrades uh were
captured and similarly executed by the
CIA trained huran Special Forces command
or the
sfc and so whether the death of most of
the huran members didn't get much
attention um us and huran uh the death
of of P Lupe u a US citizen certainly
caught the attention U multiple accounts
of his death still remain um uh sorry
while the death of the the Hur members
didn't get attention the death of of uh
Lupe did uh and the Honduran authorities
were keen on suppressing the details of
the death of pad Lupe uh because he was
a US citizen multiple accounts of his
death remained plausible one being he
was shot with a 45 caliber pistol along
with Reyes Mata another one saying that
he he died by malaria another one
decapitated another one tortured um to
death another one thrown out from a
helicopter uh however when the bodies of
the other insurgents washed out onto the
onto the river banks of the of the puka
River the authorities remained silent uh
all while claiming that he died from
starvation and illness the precise fate
of P Lupe remains unknown to this day
whether claimed by the unpredictable
Wrath of Nature and disease or by the
cover design of a CIA train operations
his story remains lar largely un told
shouted in layers of intrigue and
silence it's a silence that speaks
volumes about the very nature of Hur and
anal of the Cold War narratives his
hidden demise mirrors the Paradox of
endurance itself Central to us Cod War
agendas yet often relegated to the
footnotes of History while its terranean
politics were long deemed invaluable for
us interest its true Ro much like by
lup's death when unnoticed buried under
the weight of the larger Central
American Revolutions as Spider lupus
fate remains unsolved an unsolved
mystery so there's the question how has
a nation integral so so integral been
overlooked uh in US Cold word history um
that's uh the story of huras and how uh
it's lacked a lot of uh historical
production but within that uh a bigger
question that I had is how you lose
stories like these uh of Santos Ceno
Garcia who's a who's a black garifuna uh
communist and organizer in the 1950s um
who um was part of the L larger labor
movements in the 1950s was also part of
an anti-racist organization called the
Abraham Lincoln culture Society um and
so when the the product of this of this
of this lack of historical production
has also uh silenced this histories um
of working people working indigenous
people but also uh working um uh black
people in Honduras so uh yeah that's
sort of my intro into that my
dissertation is obviously much more
complicated but yeah that's sort of what
I wanted to leave uh everyone with him
thank you
take
questions okay uh hi everyone I'm junan
a second year Master student with focus
on environmental anthropology at school
of environment um my research examine
the indigenous environment tourism on
the tibat and plateau in China um my
research interest comes from a
contradictory observation when I work
with Tibetan conservation NGS and this
is me this is my main interlocutor and
first the homogeneous interpretation of
tiban environmentalism by Chinese
conservationist simply as tiban people
believed in sacred mountains and lakes
and then the very diverse practices
discourses of Tibetan conservation ngos
uh each Ang's articulations about why
and how we should protect nature is very
different um this made me curious about
one question how some um critical things
such as indigeny politics science are
articulated in this ngo's conservation
projects and what we can learn about
human nature coexistence from this
complex landscape so this summer I went
back to tiban plateau and stayed for
nearly three months in Four Angels and
three of them were led by Buddhist monks
and one was led by Tibetan herder um it
was quite an enjoyable journey I had a
chance to visit some old friends and met
many new faces in Theos and conservation
conferences I did interviews with uh
Theos leaders like this monks and also
did participant observation in Raptor
monitoring ecotourism and other
conservation projects and three of my
primary finding findings can be
summarized as um first the adaptability
of indigeny uh in tibetan conservation
it very much relies on environmental
leaders continuous translation between
uh Han Chinese and tiban Science and
tradition and others second a vital
landscape of tiban
environmentalism where diverse practices
and discourses coexist through similar
culture structure but very different
social context social political context
and also personal propositions of these
leaders third a general nonar
conservation knowledge of people are
Nature co-produced by these ngos it
might be the next stages of human uh Co
nature coexistence for us well the
current is more likely people and nature
in short I hope this the result of This
research can making ways for uh
indigenous people on the Tibetan plateau
and also provide alternatives to the
global conservation thank
[Applause]
you
hi everybody I'm Allan a fourth year PhD
student in the history of architecture
program uh my dissertation examines the
contested Logics of urban development on
the Texas Mexico border in the latter
half of the 20th century and focuses on
the role of design professionals namely
Architects engineers and urban planners
uh and the roles they played in the
Dynamics of the Region's Interstate
political
economy amid post-war reconstruction and
a global e Economic Development the
design profession established Newfound
footholds in society by leveraging
technical knowledge into Innovative
forms of managerial expertise with this
expertise in hand the design of the
built environment became an essential
aspect of the function of government and
access to an interconnected global
economy with the assistance of Rhythm I
was able to conduct two weeks of
archival research at the University of
Texas Benson Latin American collection
Alexander architectural archives uh
specifically the organizations I was
looking at were the American American
friend service committee collections the
Rodman C Rockefeller Mexico us business
committee files uh as well is the
collection of the American Planning
Association and a planning Professor
named uh Hugo lier who is one of the
founders of UT's planning
School the
archives as we can see from the image
presented a kaleidoscopic vision of what
the US Mexico was imagined to be between
the years of 1960 and 1990 um on one end
of the spectrum we see this Vision
includes the aspiration of modernist
Architects and local Chambers of
Commerce uh projecting a certain image
of modernity and prosperity into the
borders landscape um and on the other we
find uh what could be considered like a
certain form of urban
informality uh that presupposes a
economic structure that requires a
certain underclass
uh as border industrialization attracted
inhabitants and capital from both
Nations and elsewhere urban populations
and their economic impacts ballooned
well beyond the scope devised by
mid-century
planners uh as I see it uh Urban
informality itself is the dialectal foil
to modernist development on the border
um and if anything we have to consider
these two aspects of the built
environment and tension with each other
um these distri junctures that we're
seeing here up on the screen beg the
question of uh do Architects and
planners consider themselves willfully
ignorant of the effects of their
architectural impact or can we consider
this a d elction of professional duties
um and Civic engagement um but any
questions
okay um hi everybody uh my name is Roy
Roy slair I am a second year PhD sorry
that's a lie I'm a third year PhD
student uh in anthropology so my
research is on black queer life in the
UK um also on the weekend Friday and
Saturday there is something going on
which I'm going to just talk about so if
you could pass that along um but my
research is on blacko life in the UK but
this summer uh with rthm
I um as long as well as having money for
my research I also was part of another
project um and it's uh called inbest so
intersectional black European studies so
this is uh Berlin Cathedral and that's
obviously me um and so part of this
project and what you're going to see
from the uh little postcard there is uh
uh basically Professor Fatima El T who's
part of RM um and or ethnicity race and
migration um she is part of um a group
in Germany of black women black
feminists who are essentially trying to
digitize uh and archive um uh a lot of
different so mag different media so for
example magazines posters um so
essentially archiving uh black feminist
literature and uh
different kind of uh parapan even um
conect pertaining to uh black women uh
lesbians black people more broadly and
so uh what myself and other fellows did
we went down to uh Berlin and stayed
there for three weeks and we were part
of the project of trying to digitize a
lot of uh the different magazines that
came into uh our hands um and we went to
different places and different spaces to
connect with black Germans um so for
example we went to a place called eot
Pho um which is stands for Each one
teach one uh and so essentially it was a
learning experience where we got to
learn more about uh Germany uh or black
Germany particularly and in terms of how
this relates to my own research um it
was very fascinating to kind of um hear
the stories and experiences of black
Germans um and how they were similar and
different to the black British context
um and so one example um that one of uh
the German afrer people that we um
interacted with she would mention that
in Germany people would uh say to her oh
your German is so good um uh how come
you speak such a good German and she'll
say well I'm from here I was born here
and uh the refrain will always be uh but
where you really from and so that was
something that was definitely something
I could could connect to cuz in the UK
uh there has been a black population
there for a very long time but often um
our uh connection to the nation is
denied and repudiated so um yeah so we
were so there's a lot of different
connections there that um I can relate
to but the project more broadly um is
something that is going to continue and
on Friday and Saturday as you can see
from the uh poster that's going around
and you can turn it around as well to
stuff at the back to show you who's
coming but um yeah on Friday you're all
welcome to come and um we will be having
like different discussions and talks and
you're going to have different people um
different black Scholars and activists
from Europe coming to speak about like
their work and um black European studies
um and for example Gloria wer who's
quite well known she's a Dutch uh Black
Dutch feminist Anthropologist who will
be there and there's there will be many
other people as well and I will be there
as well um but that was kind of a quick
uh little snapshot of what I was doing
um in the summer in uh Berlin so
yeah
hi everyone my name is Zoe Lee Park I
study the normative theory of
environmental justice what should
environmental justice look like the
environmental justice movement if you
don't know what it is it's the poor
people of color movement for clean and
safe environments for all um centuries
and Decades of white supremacy have
resulted in many of these communities
living in places that are very toxic
very polluted and in my review of the
literature I found that there's still a
real disconnect between scholarly
normative arguments and then the
Grassroots arguments that I was hearing
in my own work off campus and so through
my thesis I sought to bridge this kind
of Gap um so I pursued a 14-week
embedded ethnography with two different
environmental justice organizations in
California I am from California these
are communities I really love so during
those 14 weeks I was volunteering and
really learning through that
volunteering and so for the first seven
weeks of Summer I was at Green action
for health and environmental justice
they're based in San Francisco and then
for the second seven weeks of Summer I
was at the Central Coast Alliance United
for a sustainable economy or cause for
short and cause asked for my support at
their Santa Maria Office Santa Maria is
a predominantly farmw workking community
and so through my volunteering I learned
from my communities what environmental
justice and responsibility should
include and I adopted approaches from
grounded normative Theory grounded
normative Theory out is outlined by
Professor Brooke akerly um and so I
sought to use a variety of of different
empirical methods developing ideas
recursively being inclusive of different
ways of knowing in my communities and
the rearticulating these findings in
ways back to my communities that were
helpful to them and so I organized focus
groups which were smaller discussions
with my community members and organized
presentation feedback sessions uh where
I asked my communities for my for
feedback on what I was Finding I also
attended public meetings and I conducted
several interviews and I hired three
research assistants uh three really
brilliant young women from from my
communities who supported the project
tremendously and so the goal for the
thesis is to develop normative theories
rooted in the arguments of my community
members to really help them shape policy
and Society towards their visions and so
now this semester back at Yale I am
learning how to analyze my ethnographic
field notes and as I'm analyzing my
field notes I'm combining those findings
with my two other methods which is a
Content analysis on pieces published by
these organizations and then also a
historical analysis on the histories of
my communities how those different
histories have shaped the normative
arguments they're making um and in the
spring of 2024 I'm going to be returning
to California uh to share the findings
of this study wherever my community
members want me to share local Council
meetings have come up is a really a big
one um and I'm just I'm really grateful
to the center uh for all of the ongoing
support especially it enabled me to hire
a third research assistant really
brilliant um really brilliant young
person and so yeah thankful for all the
[Music]
support